how are you Kurt I'm good how are you
love chat with your brother it just
makes me smile to think about things
that you do physically what's your
favorite what's your favorite when I
went when I had the opportunity to hit
the dunk tank
with Michael Irvin and I overshot the
throw by like four feet like is that
your favorite one or me yeah that was my
favorite because I think that was one of
the first where I truly got a glimpse
into the athleticism or lack thereof of
Rich Eisen but you know my favorite
stories always when your son was in the
studio and he threw a huge spiral and
this was what year - after you know you
didn't throw such a good spiral we're
just talking about and he threw pretty
well and you know your chest was pumping
up a little bit like tea
okay I'm learning I'm teaching my son
and I asked him so we taught you to
throw like that without hesitation he
said my nanny Katie I mean that was one
of my favorite moments on our show of
all time because you were just so ready
to explode with fries when he was gonna
say he was dead
what's that without hesitation my nanny
Katie that was that was a beautiful
moment that I will never forget you came
on my show and I asked you to complete
some physical achievement through a hole
about ten yards away you're complaining
about the type of footballs they are
you're complaining
yeah SCAP Rohan bring the pro football's
come on read the real thing like I said
it obviously you know had some retention
to it because by the end of the week
everybody was throwing the dudes that's
right well sure Shaq had just thrown the
the calamari made seven it's a memory
ladies first seven come on I hear any
complaints out of him me neither
that actually propelled him to enter the
draft he can use those little that's the
curt one I know I love right there right
there while he's on the phone before we
talk football since this might you say
this is going to upset me go ahead and
read it what do you want to tell me
right now we have some odds on who's
gonna be the next Michigan head coach
you believe beat line left Kurt can you
believe that to go to the Cavs really
surprising yeah with all the success
that he's had but come on I mean we all
know I mean you want to take your hand
at the highest level okay see how you
can do and no but yeah a lot of great
success there but I know yeah I agree I
agree so what are the odds who's gonna
be the odds-on favorite to take okay so
I oversold a little bit Chris beard is
actually the favorite he's three just
signed he's three two one okay but the
sec is the second favorite yeah Rick
Pitino Pitino is like four and a half to
one Kirk I think that that is I mean
it's more it would be more realistic it
for Michigan to destroy their program
and all of us who were so rooting for
beeline to beat Rick Pitino in a final
that has since been tainted by his
behavior okay and should be awarded to
Michigan that it would be it would be
more realistic for Michigan to torch
their program by having a Khaleesi
riding on a dragon and I tortured that's
what I think is more realistically it's
gonna be cool when you hire Pitino and
you have to play our games at midnight
because to center court no way with his
blue on shore sports book alright Curt
let's get into talk it's a for our if
you heard Josh Rosen just moments ago
but he sounded like a totally mature kid
who's enjoying his time with Fitzpatrick
in the quarterback room not like
somebody is like hey I'm entitled to get
this job right from Jump Street like
this the kid that everybody thought he
would be based on all the red flags that
I think were inappropriately applied to
him that's my obviously slanted set up
question but I'm wondering what you
think of Rosen in Miami and what the way
he's conducted himself here Kurt yeah I
think he's conducted himself has been
nothing but class and you know I think
so often when people see you know any
professional athlete but for whatever
reason you know that's kind of been the
narrative with Josh Rosen is that he's
entitled and you know he thinks things
should be given to him and all of that
stuff has kind of been the narrative all
the way from college and you know even
to the point where a lot of people were
saying on we don't really like his
demeanor because of that I don't think
we've seen anything but exactly the
opposite as he's gone through this
entire thing whether it's saying the
right thing showing up you know for team
workouts when there's all the
speculation you know the video that was
posted
you know congratulating Tyler and you
know saying thanks to the fans in the
organization to the way that he's
carrying himself now and the things that
he's saying about the organization and
as you just said on your show about
coach Kings buried in an end I mean all
of that stuff I mean he's done nothing
but say and do the right things and you
know whatever has brought that about is
that who the young man has always been
as it been through different trials and
challenges sometimes that you know that
matures us and that allows us to grow up
and step back and see the big picture
you know with with things that are going
on I don't know what it is but all I
know is he's handled it with a great
attitude with class and he's looking
forward to the new challenge you know as
he said not expecting to be handed the
football or handed the starting job but
simply to continue to learn and try to
find the best situation for him to
succeed so yeah
tip my hat to him because that's not an
easy situation you know it's not even
easy to say the right thing all the time
and you know he's done nothing but
carrying carry himself the right way and
that would have to excite me if I'm the
Miami Dolphins with the way that he's
done things in the way that he's really
set himself up as he enters our
organization and obviously we're gonna
see a lot more of who this guy is as we
move forward but you know but it but it
excites me that we made that move and
we're getting a kid that seems to be
very mature and accepting of the
situation that he's in now and excited
to work and and try to earn the position
well and then on the flip side of it too
though Kurt I mean you're there in
Arizona I'm sure the excitement level
for Kyler Murray is through the roof and
and I guess if you're gonna go bold or
go home they went bold and they and and
they got Andy Isabella I mean then they
got a couple of other wide receivers to
stock this offense how do you think it's
going to work first blush here with
Murray in Arizona um well I mean I'm
excited to see like everyone else I mean
I'm excited to see what the offense
looks like you know we've always talked
about the air raid and we've seen it at
the college level and the success that
it can garner but we've never really
seen that at the NFL level you know with
the spacing being different on the field
and the hash is being tighter and and
the athletes being better what's that
going to look like and how is that going
to work with the pieces they have I mean
I think their draft was great I'm
excited to see Tyler Murray play and you
know what he can bring from the last
level to to this level and that
excitement part of it and you hear you
know all the talk here of you know kept
Kliff Kingsbury going out and talking to
Lincoln Reilly about terminology so it's
a smooth transition so I think there's a
lot of excitement here with the pieces
they brought in and more wide receivers
and playmakers around him you know they
brought in a bunch of people in the
offseason which I really like their
moves in the offseason but the big
question is a lot of those guys that
they brought in on paper look better but
are coming off of injuries or haven't
been playing as much and so I
still think offensive line wise you know
those guys stay healthy if if on paper
or I should say on Sundays it looks like
it looks on paper now and they're better
than they've been in a long time up
front with those weapons I'm really
excited to see you know what this team
can look like and how exciting they
could be right off the you know right
out of the get-go because I'm excited
about calimary I felt he was the best
quarterback in the draft he brings a lot
to the table but I'm intrigued because I
think there are a lot of question marks
from personnel to what kind of offense
they're gonna run to what can Kyler
Murray be at this level you know with
all his talent but also you know the
height thing I think that can be an
issue I want to see if it's going to be
an issue I'm just intrigued by it
because there's so many unknowns right
now with what we're gonna see here in
Arizona and Kurt Warner my Pro Football
Hall of Fame compadre from NFL gameday
morning here on the Rich Eisen show the
other quarterbacks who got drafted last
month Haskins is clearly taking the gig
in Washington right now we'll have to
see what's going on with Daniel Jones
what do you think is going through Eli's
mind right now since obviously he might
be in the role if you will of you coming
up this year with Daniel Jones and the
role of Eli to you Kurt what do you
think about that well I mean first and
foremost knew knowing the person of Eli
Manning I think he welcomes the
opportunity to tutor a young man that
yeah I got a chance to meet him just
after the draft and just seems like a
quality young man I think they're gonna
mesh really well and I think Eli is
going to accept the role of being able
to to teach and tutor or mentor or
whatever the word you want to use
Daniel Jones I also think the beautiful
part of what the Giants have done is
they've come out and said this is the
Eli's gig we believe Eli can play and we
believe you lie is gonna be here and
play for another couple years could be
three years before Daniel Jones sees the
field and I think that helps alleviate
some of that pressure that you know they
Eli knows it's getting closer to the end
and
you know there is an end in sight and
the Giants have basically said we are
not looking to replace you we are
looking to get the guy to take over for
you when you're done and that's been the
approach now we all know in this
business just because that's the
approach doesn't mean that's how it's
going to play out if you light doesn't
play well if the team struggles then
they have that decision to make but I at
least think they've done it the right
way and laid it out the right way that
you know that they don't have any
they're not in any hurry for Daniel
Jones to see the field they just want
the next Eli Manning when that time
comes to an end and and I think Eli's
going to handle it with nothing but
class and and he's gonna be great for
Daniel Jones because of his demeanor and
the way that he's handled New York that
I think he's going to be able to help
Daniel a lot both on the field and how
to handle all the craziness of New York
off the field well I mean if I'm making
analogies here that might be so clumsy
what might be more I guess appropriate
of an analogy with what happened with
you and Eli is what's going on with
Flacco in Denver with Drew Locke and by
that I mean obviously drew Locke is not
a first overall selection being brought
in like Eli was acquired for if you want
to be technical about it for Philip
Rivers but you are in the role of Flacco
as you are a guy who won a Super Bowl in
a spot Super Bowl MVP as well in that
spot looking to get a second spark on a
career here and and so I'm wondering
what you think of Flacco now being in
Denver after what happened to him in
Baltimore what do you think of his
statement saying that he really it's not
part of his role to mentor drew Locke
yeah I just I don't understand that
mentality at all you know and again not
just Joe Flacco we've heard a number of
guys say that recently
Big Ben said that I think it was a year
ago
you know when they drafted a guy behind
him you know that it's not my role I
disagree with that I believe your role
is to help your team
be as good as it possibly can be and
yeah that's your role if you're the
starter to be prepared and be ready to
go that's to help all of your teammates
including the guy that's backing you up
or the guy that they want to take your
job at some point it's helping him be
the best Pro and be the best player that
he can be and you know the funny thing
is that you know people throw this
around like well you can't do both you
know you can't prepare and get ready to
play a game and mentor a young guy well
the bottom line is you're not taking
this guy home with you I mean it's not
like your entire job is to sit there
just for a drew Locke or whomever that
may be a Daniel Jones your job is to
show the young man how to prepare how to
be a pro you know when you're in the
office and you're watching film hey drew
come on we're gonna go watch film and
I'm gonna show you what I'm looking at
I'm going to show you how I prepare
here's what I do every night when it
when I go this is what I do on the
football field
watch me ask me questions if you wonder
why through it to this guy on this
particular play come talk to me after
the play and I'll tell you what I saw
and what I was thinking so you know
primarily that the mentoring role
happens when you're at the facility when
you're preparing anyways and it's just
taking a young man along with you to say
here here are all my secrets here's my
notebooks here's my notes here's what I
do and this is what got me to this point
and I don't know if all this will work
for you but I want to show you how I do
it and how it's worked for me and how
I've gotten to the point where I've won
a Super Bowl take what you can and then
if there's other questions you have or
anything else that you want to glean
from me just ask you know I'm here as an
open book to help you and I think you
know oftentimes when you mentor someone
it only prepares you more as a young
kids asking you a question that maybe
you've answered a million times but now
they're bringing a little more direction
toward bringing a little more light to
something that maybe you've passed on or
you know you're getting a little more
into detail because you're trying to
share that stuff with a young guy I
don't think in any way that's a
detriment to you preparing it's not like
oh I'm trying to do my work over here
and I got to go answer another question
or I got to go watch film with Drew or
you know whatever it is it's come along
you know come join me let's do this
together and learn from me in every
facet not just by osmosis because I'm
over here and you can watch me but it's
come and ask me and see and you just you
know you just open up your world to them
and say I want you to be the best that
you can be and then the second part of
that is as a competitor I always said
the same thing is I want to give every
trick of the trade to that guy competing
with me I want to give him every answer
to every test and then I want to go out
and beat him then I want to show
everybody that I'm still the best
quarterback even though it's not because
he's young and because it doesn't know
anything it's because I'm a better guy
and so not only do you make your team
better and you make the people around
you better so when you leave the
organization when you move on they're in
a better place to succeed but you're
also saying eh I want the best
competition possible because that is
only going to push me to be better
the best that I can be and to compete
every time out and bottom line is I
believe the best person should win I
believe that best person is me but if
the best person is the other guy then he
deserves to play and I don't want to
just be playing because he doesn't know
enough or because he's too young I want
to be playing because I'm the best guy
for the job and you know so I just never
understood you know no matter where you
go you know I mean in any business you
know you should take the role that yeah
I'm here to be the best that I can be
and help this organization be great but
a big part of that is making sure that
I'm bringing people along and I'm
teaching them the next thing so no
matter where I end up or how long I'm
here that I'm doing the best thing for
the organization that I'm committed to
and so I just to me it just doesn't make
sense today my job isn't you know to do
anything extra to help that young guy
out my job is to win games yeah your
jobs to win games but your job is also
to help everybody around you be better
and that doesn't have to just be your
backup that can be any
buddy on defense could be anybody on the
offensive line I get people mean people
in the front office the head coaches you
go up and talk to him your job is to do
everything you could possibly do to make
your team better so then in the minute I
have left do you think Elway's saying
some of them I mean you know I mean John
is a Pro Football Hall of Fame
quarterback too I mean what do you think
is that yeah I don't know if he's saying
anything to them you know because I
think there are guys that kind of have
that mentality that my job is to do my
job and I understand that part of it I
just think there has to be next-level
thinking and I would think the
organization and a guy like John Elway
would want Joe Flacco to be able to
share that so this quarterback that he's
drafted this year is the next guy and he
doesn't have to go find another one but
I don't know if if those things are
being said because I think a lot of
people understand as a competitor you
know what does your flag or a big bin is
talking about and hey I got a you know
devote everything to what I'm doing to
be successful I just think we make it to
black and white like I can't do the
other if I'm if I'm preparing to be
successful that's not true you got
plenty of time to be able to do both and
oftentimes like I said I think doing the
mentoring part of it only makes you
better prepared and make you sharper at
what you're doing to be more successful
when you step on the football field but
but I wouldn't be surprised if if nobody
from the organization went and talked to
Joe about those comments cuz I think a
lot of people understand you know what
he's getting at by saying that's not my
job Kirk you the man saying hi to Brenda
by the way uh Susie showed me the
photograph and I tweeted it out of in
her welding gig she made this Sansa
Stark necklace that means you're
watching like everybody else that Game
of Thrones so you know that we're big
fans so obviously you're welding and
they got some cool stuff there so yes
you saw the south side necklace and
seagulls man that's cool I got to make
one of those so it's inspired and art by
B if anybody wants metal art by v.com if
anybody wants to jump on and vice metal
art or metal jewelry she's got some
the cool stuff Kurt thanks to the call
say hi you Batman you bet that's Kirk
13:1 for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app